welcome to the overview of Amazon EBS
section Amazon elastic block store or
EBS for sure provides persistent block
level storage volumes for use with
Amazon ec2 instances in the AWS cloud
each Amazon EBS volume is automatically
replicated within its availability zone
to protect you from component failure to
offer high availability and durability
so basically EBS is the disk volumes
that you attach to your ec2 instance you
can create an e BS volume in the
management console when you create a new
EBS volume you need to define the region
and the availability zone for it
you can also create new volumes through
Amazon API or command-line tools the
screen displays an example of creating a
volume with the AWS CLI create volume
command note that the size of the volume
availability zone and the volume type is
defined in the command the region is
assumed from the default settings of AWS
CLI you can also copy a volume to a
different region using snapshots one
important point to be noted is that a
first access penalty is attached to both
Amazon EBS volumes and instant store
volumes this penalty can be a 5 to 50
percent reduction in performance on the
first read or write it is recommended
that you warn the volume in order to
eliminate this penalty from affecting
production workloads though this is not
mandatory and in many cases may not be
noticeable Amazon EBS volumes can be
stripped raid zero for performance or
configured redundant storage raid 1 by
using raid arrays you can create raid
arrays by using the standard operating
system tools
you already know you can backup the data
on your EBS volumes to Amazon s3 by
taking point in time snapshots initial
snapshot of the root or brute volume
must be consistent so it is highly
recommended to stop the instance before
making the first snapshot or freeze the
filesystem snapshot command runs and
returns asynchronously and remains in a
pending state until it is finished you
can watch the status of the snapshot in
the AWS management console or through
the API using AWS CLI tools
you can scale an Amazon EBS volume using
snapshots if you are performing the
process on the root volume be sure to
stop the instance before detaching the
original volume detach the original
volume if it is the root volume then you
will have to perform this action from
the management console or from another
Amazon ec2 instance that will continue
running create a snapshot of the
detached volume use the AWS ec2 create
volume command to create a new volume
you can specify in the command that the
volume will be created from the snapshot
you previously took of the smaller or
larger volume attach a new volume to the
stopped ec2 instance and if you expand
the root volume restart the instance
keep in mind the following points to
help you better manage snapshots use
automation to manage a large number of
snapshots across a large fleet use CLI
tools to automate creating and managing
snapshots through Linux shell and
windows batch create backup commands
using CLI and schedule them through cron
for Linux or task scheduler for Windows
use services such as AWS data pipeline
or configuration management systems like
chef to setup scheduling tasks remotely
on this screen CLI commands for three
common snapshot management operations
are displayed taking the snapshot moving
the snapshot across regions and finding
the snapshot ID and restore it to a new
volume the AWS CLI commands are
self-explanatory note that it is always
useful to pass a description for the
newly created snapshot although
snapshots are stored in Amazon s3 they
are not directly accessible using the
Amazon s3 utilities you need to use the
Amazon EBS tools to restore and manage
snapshots in this demonstration we're
going to take a quick look at EVs
snapshots
you
we'll start by going to compute ec2 and
we'll go to the volume section
now here are the two volumes the route
volumes that are attached to our simply
learned web servers so I've tagged them
is simply then web server one root and
website of a two root so we can see what
they are now to create a snapshot very
easy we highlight the volume you want to
take a snap of click on actions and
click on create snapshot then we get to
give it a name so simply then web web
server one root snap give it a
description and behold simply one web
server root and it's saying encrypted no
and that's because the root volume isn't
encrypted if this was an encrypted
volume then this would also be an
encrypted snapshot so we click on create
so snapshot creation started so if we go
to snapshots on the left hand side we
can see here
that our snapshot has already been
created so that was a quick one now if
you had a much larger volume then it
would take longer because remember it
takes the snap then it copies the
snapshot to Amazon s3 so that can
sometimes take a while so this is 100%
available so what can we do with this
well we can keep this for safekeeping
and we could take a snapshot every night
or every week of the web server so we
can restore to a point in time or if we
wanted to we could create a volume from
this particular snapshot so we could say
yep
create a new snap we could change the
different volume type so here we are as
we mentioned here the two different HDD
options which are mu as of April 2016
and we can change the availability zone
so once you have the snap you can do
pretty much anything with it in your
region you can also create an ami from
your EBS stamp shop so you can create an
image of it and you could use that to
create a new instance if you wanted to
so that's a very brief overview of
Amazon EBS snapshots hey once become an
expert in cloud computing then subscribe
to simpler Channel and click here to
watch more such videos turn it up and
get certified in cloud computing click
here